hey everyone welcome to this week's
edition of After Effects tips and tricks
I'm Cameron and this is motion science
today I want to talk a little bit about
the 3d camera I've had a whole lot of
response really great response from the
3d camera techniques video that I put up
on YouTube and the website motion
science TV the responses has been great
it's been up for about a year now but
it's just now starting to get a lot of
attention so I thought this week would
be kind of cool to talk a little more
about the 3d camera and another function
of the 3d camera that some of you may
know about beginners probably don't know
about but I want to show you so what I
have here is a video clip in my dining
room that I shot on my iPhone 7 and it's
this pretty cool statue I've got I've
got a bride and groom this is the bride
and she's just sitting on the table and
what I wanted to show you is that you
can shoot video or you can take any
video that's already been shot and you
can easily track the footage and apply
graphics to it but I'm also going to
take it one step beyond that so this is
two parts so I'm gonna go through this
kind of quick I'm trying to keep these
videos fairly short so what I'm going to
do first is all you do is you bring in
your footage I imported it here I
brought it to a new composition here it
is
iPhone 7 footage I just click once on
the piece of footage go up to animation
track camera and what its gonna do is
after effects starts tracking the data
from the camera and it's tracking to try
and solve a 3d camera from the footage
so depending on how long the clip is
this can go quickly or it can take a
little bit of time what's cool about
this effect as well is that it analyzes
in the background
so you can see here it says analyzing
background so I could actually go and
work on
things in my After Effects project file
while this is running and I don't just
have to sit here and wait for it to be
done so up here you can see the
percentage it's 54 percent of the way
it's on frame 185 24 seconds remaining
yadda yadda yadda I'm gonna pause it
real quick and come back ok so it's
finished analyzing but now it's solving
the camera and boom there it is the
analyzing and solving is done and here's
all the track points now we can see in
the footage pretty cool stuff
one thing you want to check whenever you
track a camera is you want to go into
advanced and you want to look right here
at the average error you can see it says
0.99 pixels I always aim for one pixel
or below for the average area error if
you get up in like 3 4 5 pixel errors
it's not gonna look too great sometimes
2 pixel errors can be ok but typically I
try to stay below 1 pixel hair error if
it goes and it comes above 1 pixel
sometimes you can click detailed
analysis and it'll realized in more
detail and sometimes you'll get a better
average error sometimes you'll get a
worse average error you can also click
on auto detect and click one of these
options sometimes and make sure tracking
better sometimes it doesn't it just kind
of depends it's all trial and error with
this tracker so anyways I've got the
footage tracked and I'm just going to go
up here I'm not gonna go into too much
detail about what this can do but if you
see here there's three points right here
and if I go in between them see that
circle so if I click to highlight them
and then I right-click I can click I can
select one of these options I am going
to select a shadow catcher camera and
light so what I've got now is a shadow
catcher
a light that we can't see and a 3d
camera so I'm going to go in here I'm
going to select this object I used in
the 3d camera techniques video I'm gonna
paste it in here I am going to parent
the footage to the shadow catcher and
when I hold down shift and parent watch
where it's the watch the graphics snap
to the shadow catcher see that so now
it's took it's taken on the rotation the
orientation so watch this so now it
looks like the graphic is actually
sitting on top of a statue so the
graphic is 3d and it's taking advantage
of the 3d camera that's in the scene
then we run out of the chair
oh yeah there you go this is a real time
pretty believable
pretty cool so there you go it's a
pretty easy way to add graphics to
footage that you shoot so let me let me
take this one step further now so you
saw we can do by just adding the
graphics in well I'm gonna jump back
into this comp here this is a comp that
was in 3d camera techniques where I was
talking about the orbit camera and you
may remember this from the video series
but essentially I talked about the
different types of cameras in that you
can simulate with After Effects camera
and this is the orbit so pretty cool
move but but an interesting like if you
wanted to really add some interesting
camera movement to your animation and
let's say you wanted a handheld camera
look in your animation well you know
that you can take the camera you can
click on the position property and you
can add a wiggle expression to this
property I talked about this in the 3d
camera video but if I add a wiggle
okay so I've added a wiggle expression
to the position property and we can do
more things with the wiggle expression
but to make it look better but you'll
see here so like let's say we're just
trying to emulate a simple handheld
camera move this does an okay job and
like I said I can separate dimensions of
the position and make it look better but
another way to approach this is to take
the camera that we tracked this one and
apply this camera motion to that graphic
element so all I have to do to
accomplish that is to copy my shadow
catcher which effectively I'm treating
it as a null and my 3d camera I'm gonna
copy those two I'm gonna turn off this
camera I'm gonna paste my camera and my
null and turn this off
so right here we we lose the graphic
because of the camera movement so an
easy way to fix this is to parent the
camera to the shadow catcher and then
I'm going to reposition the shadow
catcher to match like where the graphic
is at so 960 by 540 and it looks like
it's at negative 250 there we go
and then I'm also going to zero out the
orientation properties
on going to position it so my scenes in
there around a little bit and see where
I'm at here
I'm also going to change the position
zero bring it closer maybe 250 maybe 500
just trying to Center it up here turn
off my Knoll and I'm gonna Ram or I'm
gonna preview this and see what looks
like okay so here you go so this is a
camera movement on my graphic which I
mean again it just looks really it looks
real looks like it doesn't look like a
simulated CG camera it just looks like a
real camera shooting a graphic so
there's a lot of applications for this
and I just wanted to show you just the
general idea so you got kind of get what
I'm talking about here just it opens up
a new possibility for what you can do
with the 3d camera go out and shoot some
real footage track it and then it apply
it to your graphic scenes and see what
you come up with so that's it for today
I hope you enjoyed this lesson this
quick lesson and until next time I'm
Cameron and this is motion science
[Music]